and thanks all of you for coming it's
really great to be here and to share the
work that my group is doing with all of
you
so
the topic that our lab is very
interested in is computational design
for compliant dynamical robots and
to
get us into
this topic i thought i would start with
you know the idea behind computational
design right so
the idea behind our group is we're
trying to make robot design more
accessible to the general public we're
trying to think about how we can get
anybody to be able to design a custom
robot that they want so let's say this
is you
and you have an idea for a robot that
you want to create maybe you have some
idea of some general
morphology or you know what task you
wanted to do
well
in the future
we imagine that there will be systems
that will be able to help you to create
that design right even if you're not an
engineer it'll be able to ask you for
specifications help you make design
decisions and then very quickly take
that idea and turn it into a real
physical robot that you can bring home
with you and
and use for your particular task right
so when we're thinking about this sort
of problem
how do we set it up well
first of all you know we have to be able
to describe what is an actual what is a
robot right and so the way we think
about
a robot is
well it has links and joints this is a
description that you all are probably
very familiar with right because this is
a description people use in urdf files
for robot descriptions so the links are
include geometry inertia
you know other properties corresponding
to the robot's
physical
parts that take up volume right and then
the joints describe degrees of freedom
ranges of motion control etc right and
so the robot and well we're thinking
about it is a graph
that contains these parts right
in addition if we're trying to make
custom robots for different types of
tasks we need to think about what is a
task right and so in this case here your
task is a combination of an environment
which you want your robot to
be living in
and some sort of objective for what you
want your robot to do right and so
um if we have this sort of specification
then
robot design you can write down using
this very simple problem formulation
right so we want to maximize our
objective f over the space of possible
robots subject to physics right and so
this is how
we have tried to more formally think
about the problem of robot design of
course
i've hidden a lot of details in this
description
right
but i mean for different types of robot
descriptions or different types of task
descriptions you can get different types
of designs or different types of
algorithms that allow you to solve this
problem
so
when i was doing my phd at mit
we thought about well what if we want a
robot that's going to walk forward in a
flat ground and the robot is just
a
kinematic chain right
made of rigid bodies and
rotational joints
right so in that case what we can do
is we can build these systems that allow
you to compose different types of robot
geometries with different types of
kinematics
and to simulate how they
are able to locomote forward in a flat
on a flat plane
and
if all of the
you know geometries are resolved inside
of the software the software make sure
that the controller makes sense
that all that the robot can be
fabricated then we can take this design
and we can convert it into a fabrication
plan which
then you can follow and have a robot
walking around in front of you in about
30 minutes right so these are the sorts
of designs that
we know we can create
with a little bit of help from a human
in this case who is interacting with our
software
we're of course not the only people who
have done this there's a lot of uh
approaches that people take towards this
problem so what you're seeing on the
bottom left here is another system and
that was developed by stelian koroz's
group back when he was at cmu and they
were interested in well how do we also
incorporate the electromechanical
components the sensors the motors and
make sure that they have a place on the
robot body what you're seeing in the
middle
is um additional work where
encore meadow was thinking about well
how do we also take into account the
rigidity of the parts that need to be
created and how the fabrication
strategy
affects
how rigid those parts are
and so
different systems
over
time have been trying to solve this
problem of
computational robot design and have come
up with different solutions for
different aspects of the problem
so we've gotten a lot of functionality
out of these different systems
but one thing that i'd want to note is
that if we go back in time a little more
unfortunately the way that we solve
these problems and the ways that we
think about these problems compared to
approaches that showed up around 20
years ago
are not really fundamentally different
in that
back in 2000 there was also this idea of
well let's describe a robot
as a as
a graph made of rigid components and
joints and the joints of a controller
and the task is to move forward on flat
ground and we can evolve this robot and
we can also fabricate it right and so
these approaches that we've been
using in order to
make more interesting robotic structures
they allow us to
think about different types of tasks but
fundamentally the representations that
we're using for the robot and for the
task have not changed
at the same time when i show these
videos to people
they always look to me and they say well
those robots look like toys they're not
actually going to do anything right
and so these assumptions that we've made
in order to build these sorts of systems
give us
designs that move
they can move forward on flat planes
right sometimes they can move forward on
more complicated environments
but
the resulting physical designs that you
see
often
are not really going to work on a real
test that any of you might be using your
robots on right
and so
when i started at penn i
when i thought i started thinking about
this problem and i said well we really
want to make sure that the robots that
we're creating these systems were
actually useful
and so let's compare the robot that came
out of my system
to something else that somebody else
built right and so here
i took a video from you know steve
collins group you can see here
an example
of
this system which is allowing someone to
actually walk over like irregular ground
right
and so this is a system that some
engineer has actually built right
and
if you really wanted to look at the very
high level the task that it is trying to
solve is the same as the one on the left
right but there's a fundamental
difference in that in the in the way
that these systems are designed
and so
one of the observations we made was
really in the compliance of the system
right and the fact that the task on the
right is dynamic right it's dynamical
and the task on the left is really not
and so
recently my group has started to think
about this problem where the major
insight is well if we want our robots to
be actually useful
then the ability to manipulate energy
is key
and of course
this is not a particularly new insight
right people have known for years that
there's the slip model for walking
and so if you want to be able to model
how biological systems work or how
energy efficient robots might walk then
you can model it as some sort of
spring-loaded inverted pendulum system
and the way that
we
design these systems is really about
energy transfer right how we think about
how potential energy and kinetic energy
uh change our exchange
and so
this is really the inspiration behind a
lot of the work that my group has
started to do recently where we're still
very interested in this idea of
computational robot design and we want
to think about how do we make robots for
custom tasks but we've started to
integrate ideas of compliance and
energy efficiency so
we've
done a lot of
work now in compliant mechanisms how we
can create different structures with
uh
programmable compliance properties
um we've also thought about
reconfigurable structures in the sense
of well if i have a robot that i've then
tuned for a particular task
are there ways that i can manipulate
that same design in order to get it to
also perform other tasks
and a lot of the work that we've done is
also origami inspired in that these
designs that we've created can be
fabricated using folding
which we think there's a lot of value in
because it allows us to directly embed
electronics and actuators directly into
a sheet that then we turn into a 3d
robotic object
but combining all of these ideas
together then the main problem that
we've been thinking about is
can we computationally think about how
we can then use compliance
in order to enhance the capabilities of
a robot design
so
i'm not going to have time to talk about
all of these projects today i was going
to focus in on a couple
but i'm happy to talk about
other things as well if you all have
questions about them
so
thinking about
the problem of computational robot
design and compliance um then one of the
first places that
we went to was
topology optimization
some of you
may know
that you know topology optimization is
a pretty um
has been pretty successful
in
designing structures
um when we want to think about well how
what is the mechanical response of that
structure so
in um
we want to build a bridge for example or
if we want to
basically think about how a 3d object is
going to respond to forces applied to
different areas we can start with a
block of material
and we can model the physics of that of
that block
and we can change the density of certain
areas of that block in order to
manipulate the the response right and so
topology optimization is a is an
approach that
um people have used to try to solve the
problem of given a block of material
what is the particular
uh
distribution of densities that i want in
order to produce a particular response
and what you're seeing here is an
example of that type of formulation
so here
what we have is some
type of objective right some type of
force or energy that we're trying to
achieve
we have the material density on the left
this is the object that we're going to
be building
and we have some physical model for how
the material deformations
change as a function of the input forces
right and so
in addition you sometimes have some sort
of some fabrication constraints right
and so these sorts of approaches like i
said
give you um
interesting complex structures
that produce some sort of mechanical
response to given inputs right so in
this case
what
these authors were producing
was this bridge where there's
a point load in the middle and they were
trying to minimize the compliance of
that bridge what you're seeing on the
right is if there were radial forces
then
by solving this optimization problem you
get a wheel right
and so these approaches have
often been applied to static scenarios
so
we wanted to know well if now we want to
take these ideas and then do
computational design for a robot
can we take some of the same approach
right and this form of this this problem
you're seeing is very similar to the
form that i showed you on the first
slide right
so
one of the areas where
we wanted to apply this was
we were saying what is an interesting
complex and dynamical task that we might
want a robot to achieve and
my student was very inspired by the idea
of hybrid aerial vehicles these are
vehicles that have two different modes
of flight right you have this
multicopter based mode which is supposed
to be highly agile you can have vertical
takeoff and landing
and also a fixed-wing flight mode which
is highly energy efficient for long
distance flight
and at the same time
we saw this video
out of mueller's group which is this
reconfigurable quadrotor
that can morph in order to get through
small spaces
and we said well
what if i want to take this idea of
passive reconfiguration
and use it to design some sort of hybrid
aerial vehicle that can switch modes
and what if because this is a very
complex task
what if maybe we try to solve it using
topology optimization
and so
the idea behind this project was as
jessica
weekley is the student
who was leading this project and we it
was a collaboration with chen fan
fujian's group who he's at ucla
and specializes in
simulations for deformable bodies
so the idea here
was that we would take this quadrotor
right and we would put in compliant uh
structures
and we would attach a wing deployment
mechanism to this compliant structure
so that when the vehicle accelerated
then
this comply mechanism would switch and
the wings would fold in or out and we
would able we would be able to get this
vehicle that switch modes passively
by using just the actuators that are on
the robot itself
so in this case what you're seeing is a
video for
when
imaginary rotors that are at where those
orange
arrows are pointing
apply burst of thrust
and the mass in the middle right here
accelerates or decelerates
in order to switch the mechanism back
and forth
so
this problem here we thought well this
mechanism in the middle
ideal ideal application of topology
optimization but we're going to be
applying it to this really interesting
dynamical task
and so we formulated the problem it
looks
a little bit more complicated but the
form is exactly the same as what i
showed you before we have reaction
forces that we're trying to optimize we
have
um some fabrication constraints
we have
actuation constraints and using that we
started with this material block which
then we basically
optimized using gradient descent and
chianfeng fujian's
deformable body simulation and we ended
up with a beam that looked like this
which
produces
sorry a mechanical response
that looks like this
and so
the idea here is that through this
optimization
now we were able to achieve this by
stable mechanism
where each of these beams is attached to
the frame of the quadrotor and we have a
big mass in the middle right
so changing the location of this mass
results in reaction forces from these
beams that look like this curve
and so if the vehicle accelerates and
this and this platform is pushed past a
certain point right this is zero right
here
then the vehicle will automatically
switch modes
right and we said this is really great
we didn't actually have to do any of the
manual design ourselves
can we get this robot to actually work
in real life now and so we printed out
these beams and we attached it to a
quadrotor
um
how did it accelerate and what you're
seeing now is a comparison of the
physical vehicle with the simulated one
on the left so this vehicle over here is
going to accelerate and now it's
decelerating
the mass in the middle
continues its motion because it's
the actuators aren't directly attached
to it
and as a result the vehicle switches
modes
right
so we were really excited by this result
because we think it's the first time
that topology optimization has actually
been applied to a dynamical task as
opposed to just a static one like the
ones i was showing at the beginning
and so
jessica took this i took this vehicle
and she attached wings to it the wings
are fake they're just there for
visualization
but we um put the quadrat in the air and
we said well will it actually be able to
uh to switch in the air so here's the
video
the vehicle
turns right and then it accelerates and
decelerates and what you're seeing now
is that because
this mechanism switches in the middle
then the wings deploy i'll play that for
you again
and if we track this vehicle in the
motion capture system
then what you're seeing here in the
yellow dots are
uh the relative location of the center
platform compared to the frame of the
quadrator and you can see that there's a
very clear transition between
when the platform is down relative to
this frame that is the wings are folded
in
and when the platform is up
so we were really excited about this
because we said well okay we got
we we used topology optimization to
automatically design
these compliant uh arms which allowed us
to get
basically uh passive switching between
modes for this hybrid area of
aerial vehicle and we didn't have to add
any additional actuators other than
those that were already on the vehicle
right all of this transition was
achieved just through acceleration of um
just through the control
yes
i have one question about how you frame
the optimization or more like how you
solve it did you have to make some
tricks about making it differentiable
you said you use
yeah the question was about how we
formulated the optimization problem and
specifically about how i said we use
gradient
a descent
which requires gradients
and this is one of the reasons why
we were using
fanfu's
simulation it's a multi-point material
method simulation which is
differentiable
so um
yeah so all of the gradients were
calculus
calculated
any other questions
okay
great
so
like i said this we were really excited
by this result um but you'll also notice
that i paused the video at a very
convenient location
so if i continue to play the video what
you'll see
is that the vehicle flips over right
part of this is because the wings are
like i said fake they're just there for
visualization so you can see them deploy
but another reason for this is because
of the dynamics of the vehicle so if i
play back this video again it should be
clearer what's going on
and actually
this video over here is probably clear
the assumption that we were making when
we designed the controller was that the
vehicle was symmetric right
but it's very clearly not and that
there's tilting
in the platform because of gravity right
and so
um
as a result when the vehicle switches
states then there's a huge counter
torque that gets induced that causes the
vehicle to go out of control right
and so
this was um
this mean
basically what happened was that when we
formulated the problem we weren't
thinking about this right we made
assumptions about the symmetry we
neglected to take into account some
other effects of the vehicle right
and so
we're currently trying to figure out
well can we incorporate those sorts of
design criteria into our optimization
problem but at the same time
it started getting really complicated
and we said well are there other
approaches that we can take to try to
approach these sorts of dynamical
dynamical systems from a computational
approach
so
those of you who
are interested in computational design
have probably
seen this pair of papers that came out
in the in the 1990s
where people have started have been
thinking about these sorts of problems
and there's a really interesting um
comment from daniel whitney where he
said
mechanical design cannot be like vlsi
design because of interdependency
between the parts kind of like what you
just saw with the hiv
they lsi design
and programming compilers are very
modular right in that if you design a
particular subcomponent and you put it
into the rest of your design it will
work the same way every time right and
it the behavior of that component
doesn't depend on whatever else it's
connected to
but that isn't really the same when it
comes to
mechanical structures right so if i
attach my compliant beam to this frame
on the quadrotor and there's something
else in the system that's causing a
different mass distribution
the vehicle's behavior is going to be
different
right and so his claim in this paper is
that well compilers for mechanical
designs just aren't going to work
right after that there was another paper
there was a response from eric anderson
who said well you know that's kind of
true
but
instead of just saying this problem is
impossible maybe what we should be
thinking about is well when can we take
a modular approach right there are some
cases where you can design parts of your
system
and
approximate all of the other stuff
so that you can you don't have to take
all the interdependencies into account
and what we should be thinking about
instead of just throwing up our hand and
saying it's not going to work is
well when is it possible to take that
approach
so
this is kind of the other approach that
we've been taking in my research lab is
well we try we're trying on one hand to
really optimize the entire system and
we're continuing to work on the hiv now
but on the other hand we're also trying
to think about well
can we modularize the design and can we
think about individual compliant
mechanisms that then we can combine to
create this more interesting dynamical
behaviors and when is that possible to
do
without trying to optimize the whole
thing
so
um
before i continue are there any
questions
okay
so
the idea then the the other approach
that we've been thinking about in the
lab is this this idea of design
composition right
where i have a library of parts that
maybe my lab has designed or maybe
you've designed or somebody else has
designed and we know that it works for a
particular purpose
and we can drop it into a library
and
these library this library of parts has
some high level representation of what
each of the parts does
right
and now if i want to create a new design
then i can identify each of the parts in
my new design with something that's in
the database and i can combine them
together
and because each of the parts in the
database is also fabricatable then the
new design can also be fabricated right
and so
this sort of modular idea is the idea
that is taken in programming and in vlsi
and it's the sort of idea that we're
hoping you can take in certain
mechanical design scenarios
and so
one of the places then that we've been
starting to focus is
well we have these modules that we want
to combine together
some of your robot components are going
to be rigid bodies which we know how to
create but some of them are going to be
compliant bodies because as i said
before we need to have compliance in
order to to manipulate the energy of the
robot right
and so
we've been trying to design
uh
robot parts
with programmable compliance
and one of our inspirations here has
been the bellows theorem the bellows
theorem is this resulting computational
geometry
which says that if you have a structure
and
you want to change its volume
you cannot do that if the faces remain
rigid
right so the picture you can have in
your mind is like a cardboard box right
so if you have all of the faces on your
cardboard box and it's and they're fixed
that cardboard box is rigid right it's
not going to collapse unless somehow you
deform the walls of that box right
so what that means is that if we have a
structure and we want to change its
volume inherently
those faces need to deform right
and that deformation means that the
structure is is uh storing strain energy
right which means that it has some sort
of compliance or some sort of stiffness
associated with it
and further that the stiffness of the
structure
is related to
you know
how much of the face is deformed which
we can compute geometrically
right
so what you're seeing here is an example
of a bellow structure that we've
that we've been investigating
it looks like this right it's a bellow
it's it has this accordion fold pattern
which is typical of yellow structures
and up on the right you're seeing
my student compressing the structure
it's made out of thin uh poster board
but it can it is quite stiff
and the reason it can be this stiff is
because
the faces need to deform in order for
that compression to happen right
not only that but the geometry and the
amount that the faces deform are going
to depend on the particular geometrical
parameters of this structure and so if
we change for example this
this alpha angle which is in the fold
pattern that's corresponding to this 3d
shape by even just one degree
we get a huge change in the mechanical
response
and so
what is really nice now is that
we can design
the behavior of these structures purely
by changing their geometry
right
so
based on these ideas now we can
basically come up with modules that are
also parameterized by geometry but they
result in different mechan
different compliance right and so what
you're seeing here are some experiments
um that the students did to try to
figure out what is the range of
compliance that is achievable for this
bellow structure
and what they found is that the
stiffness is pretty predictable
and it's in this case there's a very
nice linear relationship between the
stiffness of the structure and
the angle of the fold
so
we can take these ideas then and we can
use these modules in particular designs
where we want to get a desired
compliance
um and we can choose the particular
parameter associated with whatever stuff
compliance that we want right
now
as a side note what i'm showing you here
is a folded structure
and you might be wondering a question
that i get a lot which is you know if
you deform this thing over and over
again
isn't it going to tear and break
um so
my student also got very invested in
this question
um and put this
the bellows that you see on the left in
through a
cyclic test over thousands of cycles and
what you're seeing here
is
a typical curve for an
origami structure which is that the
first
cycle
is very different
from all of the others
but the structure very quickly converges
to some sort of steady state cycle which
is inconsistent over all of the
following trials
and so
even though
these these devices are folded we can
use them over many many cycles and they
serve quite a long time
and the reason for this is because
actually the facial deformations that
are happening inside of the structure
are relatively small so the material
doesn't actually have to stretch that
much and it doesn't tear
so
going back to the module though
what we can do now is design some sort
of robot right
where if we have some particular desire
stiffness in mind we can now design the
the
compliant part to match that stiffness
what you're seeing here
is an example of a robot where we
actually did that
this is a jumping robot where
the top
is two and a half kilograms of just
motors
and the controller
and
power and all of that stuff which
is basically the payload of the robot
and using what we know about this
payload we can tune
or we can figure out what is the
necessary stiffness of the legs on the
bottom that are being used
to get this robot um to jump um and we
can
we can basically design these springs to
to to give us that stiffness
and the important what you're seeing
here then is that design jumping forward
consistently with a very simple rubber
style controller
and the thing i want to emphasize is
that one
the
the design
was created out of this parametrized
module
and two that the springs that are being
used to carry all of this load are
actually quite light it's only 50 grams
of folded material
not only that but because um
the
the structures are compliant then that
same design can actually locomote over
a wide variety of
terrain
so here you're seeing that exact same
design with the same controller hopping
over this obstacle course of the student
setup and of course the speed at which
it moves is going to change depending
depending on the particular environment
but it is still able to achieve this
this hopping behavior
so
um one place where we're trying to take
uh this project then in the future is
thinking more about well how do we then
integrate
um
or how do we then take advantage of the
fact that we're using origami inspired
fabrication here
and
just as a side note one of the um
sorry
one of the
places that my group
is very interested in taking advantage
of these structures is so that we can
directly integrate all of the actuators
and electronics so
we've developed these planar fabrication
approaches that you can use to put your
circuitry directly onto the structure
and hopefully we can get rid of that
huge mass of motors and wires and
everything that's on top
so when you take when you do this
process of
basically taking your circuit
transferring it onto
a sheet of plastic film which is then
essentially a flex pcb we laser cut
folds into the pet film and then we fold
it by hand then you get
these circuits that look like this if
you put it on a rigid plate or that look
like this if you put it on a thin sheet
of material
and if you also take advantage of
if you also put a layer of smart
material sheet in the middle you can
also get these structures to self-fold
so
using these sorts of ideas
then we can take
these circuits and then we can directly
transfer them onto
these jumping uh designs that i showed
you and then we can have these fully
untethered jumping systems that look
something like this
um this is the exact same bellows
pattern that i showed you on the
previous
slide but there's only one layer now
instead of all of the layers
and all of the motors now are
directly embedded inside the fold
pattern all the circuitry is directly on
top instead of us having these large
aluminum frames
and so
these structures can jump
very similarly to the larger scale robot
that you saw previously
and again just like the robot you saw
previously the geometric parameters that
control
the jumping energy for the structure
can be changed in order to get in this
case in different jump heights
so
basically then we have these modules of
compliance structures that have
different parameters associated with
different designs right and then the
question we now need to think about is
well if we want to be able to compose
these designs together can we do that
like can we always do that right
and
or can we always do that in order to get
a particular type of response
and
so one of the places where
um we've been focusing that question is
first in manipulation because this is
the
arguably the easier design
design problem
and the question we've been thinking
about
instead of just thinking about you know
very dynamical robots with that are
flying or jumping is just if we have a
particular kinematic structure that we
want to achieve with a particular
compliance profile
can we use this sort of composition
design approach in order to achieve that
that design
right
so the problem looks like this
we're representing our manipulators with
a dh specification and each of the
joints in this dh specification has a
certain stiffness associated with it
and what we want to do is try to solve
this sub problem right by
of converting this kinematic chain
directly into an origami pattern
now what's really interesting about this
problem is that
well oh well here's an illustration of
the problem
so
what's really interesting about this
problem is that because we're taking a
modular approach we can divide it into
two parts right and the first part is
what is required in the database right
in addition to
that bellows that i showed you on the
previous uh
in the previous section what other
additional parts do we actually need
and two
can we guarantee that these parts can be
composed and how do we compose them in
order to achieve a particular kinematic
chain right
so
my student weishi has put together
an expanded database of parameterized
parts they give you different geometries
and different
degrees of freedom
and
we've started tackling this problem of
can we compose these structures together
right
so
the main insight that we've had in this
section is
well
yes you can
automatically convert an automatic a dh
parameterization a dh specification of
a manipulator directly into an origami
structure
because your dh representation dictates
the locations of all of your joints
but only up to a translation
and so we can take advantage of this
extra degree of design freedom in order
to design the particular robot we're
trying to create
so our main result here is that
given this
set of modules that
can give you rotation translation
both
as a free degree of freedom or just as a
rigid transformation
and the fact that all of these modules
are parameterized so we can get a
particular range of motion after each of
the joints a particular geometry out of
each of the rigid parts
we can
always
construct a tubular crease pattern that
corresponds to a desired gauge
specification
and this is
and we have a provably correct algorithm
that will allow you to do this
not only that but because the compliance
can be specified
then
you can also add that into your
specification
and the reason we can do this is
because of our main insight at the top
but also what we found was that if we
drill down into the specifics of the
problem definition
you can actually map this problem to a
dubin's path planning problem where
there's been a lot of work in
computational geometry so we can
basically take
all of the work that people have done in
3d duven's path planning and apply them
to
this manipulator design problem
so what does that look like well if
you're interested you can download the
code and try it yourself
but i'll also walk you through what the
algorithm looks like basically
if i have
these joints that i want to connect
together
then essentially what i'm doing is i'm
taking the end of one joint
and trying to connect it to the
beginning of another joint and those are
two joints that are on this kinematic
chain right that's forming my
manipulator
and if i want to connect these two
joints together
then i can construct
a duban's path
between them
right
this path has both circular arcs and
trans and linear components and each of
those sections can be uh converted into
a fold pattern
so what that means is that if i have a
joint that i want to connect to this
side and a joint i want to connect to
that side i can always connect them with
an origami pattern so long as i can
construct this difference path
and results from computational geometry
tell us that this path always exists so
long as the joints are more than a
certain distance apart
right
and so what i can do now is i can take
my desired
manipulator design
and i can figure out
well where are the joint locations that
allow me to get this distance apart and
allow me to construct these links
between them but still maintain
the
desired degrees of freedom according to
my day specification
so what you're seeing here is that
process where for each joint i can move
it along its axis of motion without
changing the actual degree of freedom
that that joint provides right and i can
move it until it's more than
the the desired distance away from the
previous joint and i can do this in
sequence this allows me then to
construct these duvets paths between the
joints and to construct this this
origami pattern
and the mid the resulting design here is
exactly
uh corresponding to
the dh specification that was provided
at the beginning
right so once i have this pattern i can
fold it
and what you're seeing here now is the
origami pattern corresponding to
the desired compliant kinematic chain
now
this is not a chain that you would
probably ever want to use in a robot
because it's extremely complicated and
larger than it needs to be
but i think what's really nice about
this is that now we have provable
guarantees that any kinematic chain you
want to produce is possible
right
so as an illustration
we took the puma arm
right this is a
six degree of freedom manipulator
we um asked the algorithm to design as a
puma arm what you're seeing here
is the path of links that corresponds to
that arm and each of these spheres
these colored spheres is one of the
joints
this like i said it's much larger and
more complex than it than you would want
it to be
mostly because
of the additional space we needed to add
in order to prevent self-collision
if we drop some of the constraints that
are needed
in order to
avoid self-collision we get a structure
that looks like that and these are at
the same scale
and if we add a human in to actually
place all of the links for us then we
get a nice complex puma arm equivalent
which then we can fold um into an arm
that looks like that
so
essentially
what we have shown now is that at least
in the space of manipulation
we can get
an
arbitrary kinematic chain with a desired
compliance profile out of a modular
design approach
any questions
maybe i missed this like um
did you answer the question of what
components are actually necessary or did
you fix this
um
yeah or was it given the components just
what exactly
yeah so basically um yeah i kind of lost
it
so basically what we showed was that if
you want to construct this sort of arm
it's it is sufficient
um
to
the sufficient condition is that there
is a duven's path between the joints
that you are trying to connect together
right so in a dh specification there are
two different types of joints there's
your revolute joint and your prismatic
joint so we needed modules at least for
those two
and then if we wanted to connect them
together with rigid links we needed to
be able to
actually fabricate that dupen's path
which corresponds to
a circular arc module and then a linear
translation module so it turned out for
this problem that we actually only
needed four different types of modules
one for each of those components
yes um so it is actually origami um and
so the prismatic joint is based on the
bellows that i started with
um where you can compress it and then we
added in these walls on the side to
constrain the motion so that it doesn't
bend so this is still folded out of one
sheet of paper it's just kind of folding
back on itself
no problem and then
here's the revolute joint
and then these two modules over here are
rigid components this is for the
circular arc and that's for the
translation
any other questions
yep
so so we saw before um
when you were like showing how the
initial
um
coding mechanisms to
make sure like load and release it's
very different from you like up to 2000.
i'm wondering like for this case when
you're looking at how accurate you're
able to like realize the gauge
parameters like is that something that
difference so somehow you have to take
into account the timing that just come
out and inherent like air in here
yes that's a good question so i showed
in
our cyclic test that there is actually
uh some hysteresis right so
uh
back in these plots
the curve
on top is when you're compressing
and then the curve on the bottom is when
you're releasing right and so the two
fours are different
for the purpose of
the design algorithm i just told you
about we took the average
but yeah in the future if we wanted to
get a very exact
stiffness in both directions right we
would have to take that into account
um the other comment i want to make is
that the amount of
energy that you that you lose right when
compressing and decompressing or like
the difference between these two curves
is also very material dependent
so this was for
poster board right that you can get from
like
a regular art store if you used a
different material
then
then you could also get those two curves
closer together
other questions
okay
so
basically the idea then
that that we're thinking is
that since we can take an arbitrary
kinematic chain
and then convert it into a physical
design
or i mean we can take an arbitrary dh
specification and turn it into a
physical kinematic change design right
then we can incorporate this as a module
inside of our overall robot design
approach
so let's say that you have a robot that
you want to have a certain type of
mechanical behavior
then
that gives you certain control
requirements but it also gives you your
compliance specification right
that robot is going to interact with the
environment right which will give you
some
some external forces that your robot
needs to apply it needs to respond to
and all of that results in your
uh in your final robot's interaction
with the environment right
and if you want to be really um
really specific about it then all of
those parts also feedback and they they
interact with each other
right
but the particular part that we've been
concerned with is this yellow box and
the way that we think that you can
approach it now is if you have your
motor control coming in your mechanical
feedback coming in and these are parts
of your design specification
then we can chew we can turn this into
some sort of dh specification for part
of your robot we can choose the parts
corresponding to
the design we can choose
the relevant mechanical properties which
map to geometric parameters and then we
can compose them together using using
these composition approaches
and then we can we can put them on
our robot for the particular type of
motion and stiffness that we want to
achieve
okay
so
how
i had some other stuff i want to talk
about i think
it's time to wrap up though
okay
um so i'll quickly move you through some
of the other projects where we've been
applying these ideas as well then
one question that we've been thinking
about
is well
what is the particular
compliance specification that you might
want to use
in
within the context of manipulation
so in this case we've been working on
we've been working on
uh more theory now on
trying to figure out if you want your
robot arm to stabilize around a
particular end effector position you
know how do we actually figure out what
is the distribution of stiffness
throughout the arm in order to achieve
that that end effector positions with
a certain amount of stability
right and what we've shown is that
for a particular
serial manipulator
if you model it as a network of springs
then we can
derive the four kinematics of
that structure we can figure out its um
how it deforms when certain actuator
actuation
is applied
and actually if we want
it to converge to a particular end
effector position when a given actuation
when a particular input is applied
then we can solve for
the resulting
distribution of stiffnesses
again using gradient descent
and so basically here's an example where
if i have like a three link manipulator
arm and i want it
to
uh converge to that uh
purple triangle when i just pull on a
tendon down the middle so there's only a
single actuator input here
then
these
then the stiffnesses need to
need to be designed according to a
particular distribution
which you're seeing both pictorially on
the right
um and in graph representation on the
left
so what you're seeing here is that the
thinner lines are softer the thicker
lines are stiffer and so in order to get
the robot to convert to
that end effector position
we need a asymmetrical stiffness
distribution
right
not only that but
because
we have a lot of different parameters
that we can manipulate in order to
in this design
we can achieve a particular stiffness
profile right so if i want the end
effector to maintain that end effector
position
with a certain
stiffness then i can scale up or down
the stiffness along the length of the
manipulator in order to achieve that
response
so
that's one example where we've been
thinking about
how we can actually create the
specification
and then in addition we've been thinking
about other application areas where we
can apply these ideas so another project
that we've been working on is in the
domain of underwater vehicles where
again
you can try to use a soft design
in order to produce in this case forward
locomotion
so
what you're seeing here is another
origami pattern that again
is
parametrized
and that
and it produces a certain deformation
and
force response when it's compressed
right so what you're seeing here is this
pattern in the air where there's a motor
in here that's just causing it to
contract
the volume inside expands and then when
the
motor
is detached from the end of the robot
then the full pattern is released and it
reverts back to its extended state
and you can use these sorts of ideas in
for example
swimming where if you put this robot
under water then it'll inject and then
expel water that'll allow it to push
itself forward right
so in this case again
the compliance of the robot is extremely
important to its behavior and so
here instead of just thinking about well
what is
the payload that a legged robot needs to
achieve and therefore what's the
stiffness of the leg we're trying to
think about well what is the influence
of the surrounding fluid
on the robot how does the interaction
between the softness of the body and the
surrounding fluid affect its its uh
forward locomotion and its cost of
transport
and so
zooming out then
our big idea is how do we now that we
have these algorithms that allow us to
design for particular compliance
in different scenarios how do we figure
out what are the task objectives right
how do we actually map the particular
behavior that we want the robot to
achieve in terms of trajectory or energy
efficiency or you know something else
into
something that we can evaluate so then
we can incorp we can use it as the
inputs to the algorithms that i've shown
so to close off i'll just note that all
of this work was done
by my lab members both human and
non-human as well as
in close collaboration with a lot of
really amazing people
and with that i'm happy to answer any
other questions
[Applause]
okay we have two minutes per question
and i'm glad we got the chance to answer
some already but
what do we have left
yeah
here we also be possible to include the
choice of actuators into the
optimization is it always decision by
the human
yeah the question was can we also
incorporate uh the choice of actuators
um yes and that's a slide that i skipped
over
let me pull it up real quick that um
there is a question about like what are
the actuators that you actually want to
use in this robot right because the
actuators need to produce the right
forces and speeds and whatever else that
you need
to
move the design and so
a lot of existing computational design
systems will assume you're using a
particular actuator it's just whatever
they have in the bin
um but what we've been trying to figure
out is
now if you have a particular dynamical
response that you want from your robot
that
gives you certain actuation requirements
right and those actuation requirements
can be used to pull from a database of
motors which one is the most appropriate
but at the same time that motor
and the associated electronics control
transmission etc
will add mass to your robot which then
affects its dynamical response right so
what you end up with is some sort of
iterative design loop where you have to
try to figure out well given a
particular robot what's the correct
activation given a particular actuation
how do i want to change the robot design
and this is one place where we've
started to try to think about
interdependency between
modules of robot design
not trying to design them both
together simultaneously but more
iteratively going back and forth